joining us now with more Texas
Congressman Troy Nels and Congressman
chip Roy Congressman Nell it's good to
see you let's start with you you know
look at what happened in Martha's
Vineyard and then look at what on
average I think El Paso is taking in
what 2 000 people on average a day right
now
Sean thanks for having me Texas is
inundated we have estimates of 10 000
immigrants coming through our Southern
border each and every day and they're
going to complain up in Martha Vineyard
and in New York City but I tell you as a
former Sheriff I'm concerned about the
number of people coming through and that
report on Venezuela if you don't recall
June 16 2015 when Donald Trump announced
he walked down the escalator he said he
announced he's running for president he
told the American people the truth he
said that these individuals these
countries aren't going to send their
best and what do we know he was right
they're sending rapists they're sending
murders and the dishonest media called
Donald Trump the racist but Donald Trump
was right all along so I I think it's a
sad State of Affairs what's happened in
this country and if we want to solve
this unprecedented border crisis we need
Donald Trump in 2024. you know chip Roy
I'm looking at this we now set a new
record you know as well as anybody the
state of Texas more than any other state
of maybe Arizona can compete with you
but two million people a record and it's
only September what does that make 3
million by the end of the year of
illegal immigrants that we know cross
the border not the ones that we don't
know about
yeah the known gotaways are the real
problem these are the Bad actors coming
in between ports of Entry while border
patrol is distracted but look you've got
a bunch of rich people to mark this
Vineyard who sorry to interrupt you
between your sip of wine and that cheese
plate sitting in your in your lap but
you got 53 people who come up there and
you're like oh oh my gosh we've got some
migrants here how about the 53 migrants
that were found in a tractor trailer in
San Antonio who are dead how about the
migrants you were just talking about who
have these PVC plastic makeshift markers
on graves how about the little girls
being sold in the sex trafficking trade
and how about the dead Americans like
the four students in Hayes County where
I live who have been who've died from
fentanyl poisonings or the 72 000
Americans who have died from fentanyl
poisonings in the last year which Sean
by the way is more than all of the
American casualties in the Vietnam War
that's what's going on there's a war
against the American people being
carried out by cartels and this
Administration is facilitating it and
they need to be held accountable for it
we ought to impeach my orcas and
importantly repub Republicans should not
provide one more Penny not one more
Penny to fund a DHS to 60 billion
dollars being used to facilitate cartels
to attack the American people and by the
way my friend Troy there my colleague is
a former Sheriff he ought to be the
sheriff in Bexar County we need we need
a sheriff there who isn't going to go
try to uh you know investigate Governor
DeSantis for daring to highlight and
Spotlight this issue well Congressman
Roy chip Roy let me go back to you for a
second here you want to blame mayorcus
and I agree with you he should be held
accountable what I see happening is we
have laws in this country our laws are
based on our constitution uh when you
don't abide by the law you get in
trouble but you got a case where a
president is not enforcing the law you
have a case where a president is aiding
and abetting law breaking and if I went
down to the border and I put people in
the back of my car or I transported them
to another state wouldn't I get arrested
for human trafficking isn't that against
the law and how is it the president gets
to pick and choose what laws going to
enforce and what laws he doesn't want to
enforce
yeah that's a great question Sean he
shouldn't be able to do that the reason
I'm focusing on Alejandro mallorcas is
he actually was brought before the house
Judiciary Committee where your friend
and mine Jim Jordan is the ranking
member and my work has lied to
Congressman Jordan and to me he lied and
said they have operational control of
the Border he smirked he laughed at it
he laughed at what's happening to the
American people he laughed and
disregarded what's happening in migrants
yes he's disregarding the laws purposely
he's doing it on behalf of the president
of the United States who should also be
held accountable blood is on their hands
dead Americans I've met with those moms
who have had to try to resuscitate their
children in their own homes and that are
carried out of their house in a body bag
because they took a pill and as the DEA
says one pill can kill this
Administration knows what they're doing
and they're doing it on purpose they
blame they want to blame DeSantis and
Abbott saying that they're using these
people as pawns no it is Democrats who
are using migrants as pawns to carry out
their political Endeavors and they're
endangering the American people and
migrants in the process you know Troy
Nels I'll give you the last word on this
but it seems to me that when Joe Biden
and Kamala Harris said the border is
secure and they say it repeatedly and we
don't have a crisis at the border
they're lying and they're not being held
accountable to the laws that they swore
a note to uphold didn't they swear upon
the Constitution they don't uphold the
laws of the land
well I think the American people
understand that uh she's she's she's
ridiculous everything she said you can't
believe what she said she's embarrassing
to our country and if she is the true
borders I will get down there and solve
the problem but she doesn't want to
solve the problem this is by Design they
don't want to solve this crisis millions
of people coming in here this
Administration puts the American people
last they put the American people last
they always have and now the American
people are going to pay for it but I
tell you what the American people are
paying attention and it's going to be
we're going to knock him right over the
head in November and the voters about
100 billion dollars this will all cost
when all said and done according to
estimates Congressman Ellis Congressman
Sean we should we shouldn't continue to
fund this we should stop funding that's
right uh thank you both hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else